À l'ANP 12 à aujourd'hui,
la situation reste très tendue.
Ils sont des centaines bloquées
à attendre leur tour pour être enregistrée.
Lampédouza est 1 centre d'accueil pour les migrants,
la porte d'entrée vers l'Europe.
Ça, c'est la carte d'enregistrement qu'ils m'ont donné.
Puis ils m'ont demandé de prendre mes empreintes.
Moi, je veux juste partir d'ici,
j'irai là où l'Europe veut bien de moi.
Objectif de ces centres dédiés,
faire 1 1ère tri entre réfugiés
éligible à la demande d'asile
et migrants économiques qui peuvent te être expulsés.
Mais leur capacité est limitée.
Lampédouza peut normalement accueillir 400 personnes.
On a eu plus de 6000 personnes dans le centre.
On avait pas le
temps de faire toutes les procédures d'enregistrement.
Autre outil de contrôle des frontières,
l'agence
européenne des gares de frontière et gare de Côte,
frontex. Son budget annuel n'a cessé d'augmenter.
Il est
passé de quatre-vingt-six 1.000.000 d'euros par an
en deux-mille-douze
à huit-cent-quarante-cinq 1.000.000 cette année.
Plus de 2000 agents
y travaillent désormais à temps plein.
Ça ne laisse plus,
euh, 1 seul pays de l'Union européenne,
l'Italie principalement. En disant, 1 poignée
de pays de l'Union européenne, seul face à
cette afflux de migrants.
Enfin, l'Union européenne tente depuis quelques années
d'externaliser des contrôles
en passant des accords avec les pays de départ ou de
transit des migrants,
au Sénégal ou en Libye par exemple.
L'union a dépensé beaucoup d'argent
pour financer
des postes frontières
et tenter de dissuader les migrants sur le trajet,
former. Les agents sur place,
mais aussi fournir du matériel de surveillance. Euh,
tout particulièrement
entre deux-mille-quinze et deux-mille-vingt-et-un.
Lui a investi plus de 5.000.000.000 d'euros.
Euh, dans cette politique.
Malgré les sommes colossales dépensées
pour tenter de contrôler l'immigration,
l'efficacité de ces dispositifs reste limitée.
Gérald Darmanin
rencontrer son homologue italien dans les prochains
jours.